ja manchmal werden in diesen tagen die
abstandsregel übrigens auch extrem
penibel eingehaltene zum beispiel
neulich in ankara als ursula von der
leyen war ein besuch in der türkei zehn
meter entfernt vom eu ratspräsidenten
michelle und sultan erdogan allein auf
der couch sitzen musste und es ist nur
so ein gefühl von mir aber ich glaube
sie hat es nicht kommen sehen
denn für von der leyen ist neben erdogan
und michelle kein platz vorgesehen ein
affront den die kommissionspräsidentin
so kommentiert schön subtiler bis von
uschi denn m rückwärts heißt mehr denken
sie da mal drüber nach jetzt nicht im
heute-show fanshop das original oem aus
ankara als klingelton wunderbar die
türkische ausrede war in dem fall luxe
frauenfeindlichkeit 1 1 star michelle
hätte protokollarisch halb den höheren
rang
deswegen durfte nur er neben erdo sitzen
wobei damals als jean claude juncker
noch ossis job hatte musste der nicht
aufs katzen sofa es bestimmt zu fall
übrigens erdogan des besuchs zimmer
gibt's jetzt komplett im türkischen
ikea-katalog die stuhl gruppe erdogan
vergoldetes massivholz mit seiten bezug
inklusive kostenlosem zusammenbau durch
fünf inhaftierte journalisten und
natürlich das so vermögen für nur 79
euro kann man auch ohne uschi drauf
bestellen kostet dann aber natürlich
extra und während scharen
geschäftskollege sich im nachhinein
große vorwürfe macht warum er nicht auch
ihm gesagt hat gab es wenigstens aus
italien
deutliche worte in der sogenannten super
geld affäre hat italiens regierungschef
mario draghi dem türkischen präsidenten
recep tayyip erdogan als diktator
bezeichnet in ankara sorgten die
äußerungen für empörung außenminister
mevlüt cavusoglu inhalte sie hässlich
und unvernünftig meine mutter ist
unvernünftig ist einfach die hässliche
wahrheit natürlich diktatoren
was soll erdogan denn sonst von beruf
sei dass die eu ernsthaft zum kaffee
vorbei kommt während in seiner türkei
die nächste repressionswelle rollt
das war doch ein diplomatischer triumph
für den mann ein triumph erdogan will
jetzt gerade die hdp die drittgrößte
partei der türkei verbieten lassen fast
700 hdp vertreter sollen für fünf jahre
politikverbot haben mehr diktator geht
ja wohl kaum
aldi ist kein großes thema beim besuch
der eu kommissionspräsident in ursula
von der leyen in ankara am dienstag
menschenrechte erwähnte sie am rand
genau und zwar am rande vom sofa wenn
die türkei liegt in sachen
pressefreiheit auf rang 154 von 180 und
liefert sich ein rennen mit china um
platz eins bei den meisten eingesperrten
journalisten
trotzdem stellt die eu dieser türkei
ausgerechnet jetzt eine ausweitung der
zollunion in aussicht als zitat anreiz
für konstruktives verhalten vielleicht
auch als vorauseilende belohnung für
erdogans gerade erst verkündeten achtung
aktionsplan menschenrechte ja sie haben
richtig gehört
erdogan plant jetzt wartet mit
menschenrechten auf dem papier schon
dünner ehemaliger gefügigen
chefredakteur im deutschen exil dem in
der türkei 27 jahre haft drohen findet
nur so mittel witzig smoking zu wie ihr
neues album the press conference of
losing you play 13 und soft touch screen
in finnland platz ist prosecutors and
investigations zeckenbiss opposite bord
die fdp im moment so etwas gebe was ich
immer sage das wichtigste an einem guten
weg ist das timing
das ganze interview mit jan denn da
finden sie übrigens im faktencheck auf
heute.de erdogan das regierungsbündnis
hat aktuell in umfragen keine mehrheit
mehr
was macht man da als er die opposition
verbieten und ein kasten was denn sonst
das schon mal als kleine anregung für
die cdu im september den schief geht die
oppositionelle hdp fordert gleiche
rechte für kurden was in erdogans türkei
natürlich gleichbedeutend ist mit
terrorismus und selbst gewählte
terroristen muss man natürlich verhaften
den abgeordneten und
menschenrechtsaktivisten immer mehr
fahrer gary etwa er wurde vergangenen
freitag in seiner wohnung verhaftet
zweieinhalb jahre soll er hinter gitter
weil er eine nachricht geteilt habe die
als terroristische propaganda eingestuft
wurde ja keine schönen bilder aber
tatsache ist der mann hat was über seine
hoffnung auf frieden getwittert da muss
er sich dann auch nicht wundern
kurz gesagt erdogan stoller aktionsplan
menschenrechte ist nur ein billiger pr
trick um die eu einzuholen denn erdogan
braucht hilfe ist eine wirtschaft liegt
am boden
man könnte auch sagen es kalif schon mal
besser für ihn
ausländische investoren ihr geld aus der
türkei ab die inflation geht regelrecht
durch die decke
um die bürger von wirtschaftlichen
problemen abzulenken werden andere
themen in den vordergrund gerückt aber
im türkischen gibt es ein schönes
sprichwort die mütze ist runtergefallen
die glatze nun sichtbar
übrigens wenn der türkei behauptet dass
erdogan eine glatze hat ist natürlich
auch terror ist logisch jetzt wäre die
gelegenheit als eu druck zu machen
immerhin hat von der leyen in ankara
kritisiert dass die türkei aus der
istanbul konvention aussteigt also dem
abkommen des europarats zur bekämpfung
von gewalt gegen frauen
offizielle begründung der türkei die
istanbul konvention würde zitat
homosexualität normalisieren
den zusammenhang habe ich ehrlich gesagt
nicht ganz verstanden
hier türkische staatsfernsehen
[Musik]
die türkische regierung warnt vor reisen
nach deutschland weil zu wenig deutsche
ihre frauen schlagen gibt es dort leider
überall homosexuelle wie diese
erschreckenden bilder der deutschen
armee beweisen
echte männer beantragen schon asyl in
der türkei weil sie vom schwulen
deutschen system zum veganer gemacht
wurden und im berliner reichstag schaut
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel tatenlos
zu weil ihr mann sie nicht schlägt guten
abend
[Musik]
ja der wahre grund für den eu
kuschelkurs ist natürlich sehr armes
weiterhin die sache mit den flüchtlingen
brüssel und berlin brauchen erdogan als
türsteher wobei der moral weltmeister eu
selber längst auf abschreckung setzt
hier bilder von einem so genannten push
back die griechische küstenwache macht
ordentlich wellen gegen ein
flüchtlingsboot als kleine umkehr hilfe
anruf aus stockholm
wir möchten von der eu ihren
friedensnobelpreis zurück sofort ja
solche pusch becks kommen inzwischen
regelmäßig vor und sogar flüchtlinge die
es an land schaffen werden von den
griechen manchmal im bote gesetzt und
zurückgeschoben
fazit wenn man sich das alles angeguckt
hat man den eindruck die eu passt sich
in sachen rechtsstaatlichkeit er der
türkei an als umgekehrt
wir schalten wir live nach brüssel zu
albrecht humboldt von der leyens
protokollchef der humboldt hätte man
sich als eu diese blamage in ankara
nicht ersparen können indem man ja zum
beispiel gar nicht er fliegt ich gebe
ihnen da völlig recht herr welke stuhl
geht war eine zäsur
es gibt eine zeit vor stuhl geht und
eine zeit nach stuhl diät hätte so nie
passieren dürfen was für eine demütigung
wichtig ist dass man daraus lernt ich
las die chefin jetzt jeden tag drei
stunden trainieren reise nach jerusalem
[Musik]
sie hat da leider gar kein talent sonst
kann sie so viel sie kann fließend
englisch französisch sie kann weit
händisch beraterverträge unterschreiben
aber reise nach jerusalem ist einfach
nicht ihr ding
aber warum gönnt man erdogan ohne not so
ein propaganda fest warum hat sie nicht
einfach gesagt kein stuhl keine
gespräche mit ich gehe nach hause
warum warum weil wir die eier lose eu
sind und nimmt doch keiner mehr ernst
egal ob schwedischer impfstoffhersteller
oder türkischer das boot wir drücken uns
für jeden entschuldigung
mir steckt halt noch stuhl geht in den
knochen aber das wird jetzt alles
restlos aufgeklärt im eu parlament gab
es deswegen gerade kein scherz eine
anhörung george l und ursula von der
leyen stellten sich den fraktionschefs
um zu erklären was genau im türkischen
präsidentenpalast geschaut wieviel und
von der leyen wurden aufgefordert in den
nächsten zwei wochen vorschläge
vorzulegen wie ein solcher
protokollarischer fauxpas in zukunft
vermieden werden können
ich habe hier eine ganze liste von
vorschlägen vorschlag 1 dritten stuhl
hinstellen ende der liste
ja toll statt die zeit mit anhörung über
stühle zu verplempern könnte man als sie
ja auch mal rückgrat zeigen die
beitrittsgespräche mit erdogan aussetzen
er hat nach der wirtschaftskrise an der
backe und steht mit dem rücken zur wand
das ist richtig und nur brüssel schaffte
es einem der mit dem rücken zur wand
steht noch in den arsch zu kriechen
es war ja auch nicht alles schlecht in
ankara
frau von der leyen durfte beim
abendessen bei den großen sitzen und
sogar mit aufs foto ist echt schön
geworden immer nach vorne gucken positiv
denken das ist europa ich kann
jedenfalls heute stolz versprechen stuhl
geht wird sich nicht wiederholen
ein team von ingenieuren und designern
hat für mich die lösung entwickelt da
ein diktator hat keinen stuhl mehr für
sie frei kein problem mit dem anti stuhl
geht stuhl uschi 5000 haben sie immer
ihren eigenen stuhl dabei ja ich war
noch nie so stolz europäer zu sein
albrecht humboldt
na ja genau ja ja die zuschauer
mittlerweile fast alle versteckten
symbole bei uns im neuen studio gefunden
wie laminat die freimaurer staatsführung
ist alles dabei dann wollen wir denn die
eigentlichen strippenzieher bekanntgeben
erst bei so vielen abonnenten auf
youtube also ich würde mich ran halten